une réponse militaire et technique aux
menaces occidentales c'est la rhétorique
à la mi-journée de vladimir poutine le
chef du kremlin a dirigé le traditionnel
sommet des hauts responsables du
ministère russe de la défense en
filigrane les tensions liées à la
situation en ukraine la correspondance à
moscou dans tollé clairoix
rapidement lors de son intervention le
président russe a abordé la situation
épineuse dans l'est de l'ukraine manière
poutine alerter sur la menace que ferait
planer le déploiement d'armes
stratégiques américaines dans le
voisinage proche de la russie en
particulier en ukraine nous sommes
préoccupés de voir qu'à proximité des
frontières de la russie la force de
défense antimissile américaine ne cesse
de se développer et
avec notamment des systèmes d'armes
tomahawk
et si cela se poursuit de cette façon si
les systèmes de missiles américains
les de l'otan apparaissent
dans en ukraine ça veut dire que le
temps de vol des missiles occidentaux
jusqu'à moscou serait dur à 5 ou 10
minutes
et à cet égard et comme vous le savez je
proposerai au président américain
de négocier sur certains mesures très
concrètes des en réalité d'ailleurs au
cours de la discussion il a lui même
proposé de nommer des responsables pour
gérer ces
négociations et donc nous allons faire
nous continuer à faire de nos
propositions pour éviter toute extension
de l'otan et
développement d'armes offensives dans
les territoires adjacents à la
fédération de russie vladimir poutine
est ensuite quelque peu remonter dans le
temps pour constater qu'à une époque et
bien pas si lointaine russie et
etats-unis- coopérer sur de nombreux
sujets des conseillers américains
venaient même discuter avec le
gouvernement russe malgré la bonne
volonté de moscou l'otan continue son
extension vers l'est et washington
financé des groupes terroristes dans le
caucase par exemple et pour ces raisons
le président russe impute à washington
la responsabilité de la dégradation des
relations entre les deux pays il y avait
des conseillers américains qui
travaillent qui travaillent dans le
gouvernement russe et qui apporte qui
apportèrent leur conseille comme on dit
alors pourquoi encore soutenir le
séparatisme dans le caucase du nord et
encore l'état islamique
9 un papa l'état islamique mais d'autres
organisations terroristes islamistes ils
les soutenaient ouvertement pourquoi
pourquoi faire ça pour quoi agrandir
l'otan encore pourquoi cette question de
la défense antimissile
tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui il ya
des tensions qui se mettent c'est leur
faute c'est leur faute à eux à chaque
pas la russie était bien objet de
répondre à chaque fois à chaque pas la
situation ne faisait que s'aggraver
toujours et toujours et aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans cette situation où nous
sommes obligés de prendre des décisions
on peut pas les laisser continuer à
faire dégénérer cette situation vladimir
poutine a profité de l'occasion pour
féliciter ses troupes en faisant savoir
qu'elle avait rempli toutes leurs
missions que ce soit en syrie leur
mission de maintien de la paix dans le
haut karabakh ou encore dans le cadre de
la lutte contre le coc vie 19 mai c'est
bien la position forte de vladimir
poutine sur la situation dans l'est de
l'ukraine que leur tiendra à savoir que
la russie se réserve le droit de
répondre de façon militaire et technique
à toute escalade américaine en ukraine